voilà novembre c'est terminé et la fin
du mois de novembre ça veut dire trois
choses on ouvre les cases du calendrier
pour savoir combien dodo il reste avant
noël les moustaches disparaissent et on
se palpe les testicules et lui la fin du
mois de novembre sa marque aussi la fin
de mauvaises moeurs savez le mois où on
se laisse pousser la moustache pour quoi
faire pour sensibiliser au cancer
masculin
bonjour ouah je me sens tellement
sensibiliser au cancer masculin
maintenant non en réalité - wenders a
pour but de sensibiliser au cancer
masculin en faisant parler du sujet
comme octobre rose avec les cancers du
sein mais c'est aussi une façon de
récolter des fonds
bonjour pour vos recherches
bon alors les cancers masculins c'est
quoi alors il ya le cancer de la
prostate et son dépistage dont on a déjà
parlé si vous vous souvenez mais il ya
aussi le cancer des testicules
le cancer du testicule se développent
généralement à partir des cellules qui
produisent les spermatozoïdes qu'on
appelle les cellules germinales il y a
deux types de tumeurs mais dans tous les
cas le traitement c'est de retirer le
testicule atteint ensuite on peut
compléter le traitement avec de la
chimiothérapie ou des rayons et comme
pour les cancers du sein on peut ensuite
envisager une chirurgie reconstructrices
c'est à dire une prothèse c'est purement
esthétique mais c'est important
en gros c'est une prothèse remplis de
gel de silicone ou d'eau salée qu'on
implante dans les bourses à la place du
testicule qu'on a retirés pour que
visuellement de l'extérieur.tous
paraissent normales
visuellement seulement 1 est ce qu'au
toucher c'est un peu différent il paraît
bon ça c'est pour l'aspect esthétique
mais si on a envie de se reproduire et
bien le cancer du testicule ça ne rend
pas nécessairement stérile par contre
les traitements ça peut pas
obligatoirement pas forcément
définitivement mais ça peut du coup
avant de commencer le traitement on peut
faire un recueil de sperme
je vous fais pas de dessin ou imaginées
à peu près comment ça peut se passer
puis on le congèle et on le conserve
sous forme de paillettes
ensuite le jour où on a envie de
procréer on récupère l'échantillon et
hop on est d'accord ça c'est pour faire
des bébés
mais pour ce qui es copulation récréatif
ça se passe exactement de la même façon
avec deux testicules ou avec un seul
une fois qu'on est remise du choc de
l'opération et des traitements bien sûr
bon mais comment on sait qu'on a un
cancer des testicules pour établir le
diagnostic le médecin fait une
échographie des deux testicules
même si c'est rare que les deux
instituts soient atteints en même temps
puis il complète l'examen avec une prise
de sang pour rechercher les marqueurs
spécifiques du cancer des testicules
la plupart du temps ce qui déclenche
tout ça c'est l'apparition d'une
grosseur qui peut être découvert par le
médecin par exemple
bon je sais pas vous mais moi mon
médecin à moi ils me parlent pas les
joyeuses à chaque fois que je vais le
voir il les regarde même pas vraiment à
vrai dire
et comme en plus je veux pas le voir
souvent et bien figurez-vous que de la
même façon qu'il existe une technique
d'auto palpation des seins pour dépister
les signes précoces de cancer certains
pays recommandent de s'examiner
régulièrement les roubines les
testicules au canada par exemple on
recommande de le faire une fois par mois
dès l'âge de 15 ans alors pourquoi 15
ans parce que le cancer des testicules
est le cancer le plus fréquent chez les
hommes âgés de 15 à 35 ans et que 85%
des diagnostics se font entre l'âge de
15 et de 49 ans même si l'auto palpation
des testicules ne fait pas partie des
recommandations officielles en france je
vous propose de voir quand même comment
ça se pratique bon après vous faites ce
que vous voulez de vous l'idée c'est
d'apprendre à repérer tout changement
suspect mais pour ça il faut bien
connaître ses testicules est donc
avantageux dans un clip de miley cyrus
et ça
c'est tellement génial à kaunas comme un
succès pour réaliser ce tuto sans me
faire bannir des réseaux sociaux
j'ai mis au point en laboratoire un
simulateur testiculaire qui a bénéficié
des dernières technologies en la matière
après une étude menée sur un panel
représentatif de une paire de testicules
j'ai mis au point ce prototype composé
d'une bourse en tissu et de deux
varangues la cct mais passons à la
démonstration avant d'y mettre les mains
commencer par examiner vos testicules
avec vos yeux pour éviter un tour de
remplacer vous face à un miroir est
observée l'aspect la forme et la taille
de vos bourses à la recherche de quelque
chose d'inhabituel ensuite idéalement
après une douche ou un bain chaud pour
que tout le matériel soit bien détendu
soupeser vos testicules en étant bien
attentif à vos sensations pour finir
place et l'index et le majeur derrière
le testicule le pouce devant et
faites-le rouler délicatement entre vos
doigts
ensuite recommencer avec le second
si vous ressentez quelque chose
d'anormal ou d'inhabituel comme une
asymétrie par exemple une vraie à la
base c'est normal que les deux soient
pas exactement pareil si vous sentez une
grosse heure 6 est plus sensible que
d'habitude prenez rendez vous chez votre
médecin
n'hésitez jamais à vous faire aider et
demandé son avis à quelqu'un qui connaît
bien vos testicules comme une votre
partenaire si vous êtes en couple votre
maman si vous êtes chez nous où tout
notre village
si vous êtes mormons le cancer des
testicules est un cancer relativement
rares il ya 2200 personnes touchées
environ chaque année en france mais le
nombre de cas augmente dans tous les
pays industrialisés et il peut être
guéri dans 9 cas sur 10 il est cuit en
charge suffisamment tôt tu as fait deux
bonnes raisons d'être à l'écouté de ses
testicules
vas-y tonton poitou charentes
dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui prenez
soin de vos bourses et de celle des
autres on se retrouve très vite pour une
nouvelle vidéo en attendant mettez vous
bien et surtout porté beaucoup il portez
vous bien